ROB DODSON: Hey guys.
What's up?
It's Rob Dodson here from the
Google Developer Relations
team.
And today, I want to
talk to you about how
you can create your
own responsive UI
elements using Polymer.
Now, Polymer's a
new kind of library
for creating custom HTML tags.
And with that comes
the ability to do
things like bake
responsiveness in by default.
That's a really awesome feature.
As recent studies have
shown, the average person
is interacting with about
three different devices a day,
oftentimes beginning
a task on one device
and later finishing
it on another one.
Now, as web developers,
it's our responsibility
to make sure the experiences
that we create work well
in this new multi-device world.
But HTML and CSS
don't always give us
the best tools for
completing that job.
That's where a
library like Polymer
can actually jump in
and really help us out.
Now as I mentioned, Polymer's
for creating custom HTML
elements.
Under the hood, it's
actually using a new set
of emerging standards called
web components, which basically
give developers access to
the same low level APIs
that the browser
makers use when they
implement their own elements.
Now, from a high level,
that means we actually
have the ability to create
a whole new ecosystem
of shared, responsive,
performant HTML elements.
And when the tools we use
are performant by default,
it makes the whole
process of supporting
the multi-screen web
that much easier.
So in this video,
I'm going to show you
how to create a responsive
Polymer element.
We're actually going to make a
little collapsing toolbar tag
that's going to take
all of its anchors
and put them into a
little menu button.
But most importantly, every
technique that we cover here
can be applied to any
responsive element
that we build using Polymer.
Now, as we're
working, we're going
to be building
something that's got
to be shared with
other developers.
So we've got to
constantly ask ourselves,
how can I make this
flexible for others to use?
The first part in this
process is figuring out
when we want to change the
appearance of our element.
Every site is going to have
different amounts of content
and layout, and in particular
at different screen sizes,
it's going to need to know
when to update its appearance.
Let me show you an example
of what I'm talking about.
So over here, I've got about
nine items in my toolbar,
meaning my toolbar can only
be about 900 pixels before it
needs to collapse.
But over here, I've got
four items in my toolbar.
So my toolbar can be
as small as 500 pixels
before it needs to collapse.
Every site's going to
have this same issue
of having different
amounts of content.
So how can I create
a responsive element
that doesn't bake in
all of its break points?
One option is to
allow the developer
to actually pass
in a breakpoint,
to actually configure my
element from the outside
and tell me when they
want it to collapse.
Now, to make this happen,
the Polymer team's
created the core
media query element.
Under the hood, the core
media query element's
going to check the
size of the view port
and see when it matches a
developer provided breakpoint.
Let me show you how that works.
So over here, I've got a
core media query element.
And I've gone ahead and
configured it's query attribute
to have a maximum
width of 500 pixels,
meaning when the screen size
is less than 500 pixels,
it's going to go ahead and set
its query matches attribute
to true.
And this means we can actually
create our own binding called
small screen and set it to
the value of query matches.
When the screen is
less than 500 pixels,
it's going to set
small screen to true.
And now any element that's
watching small screen
will know that it's time
to update its appearance.
So let's actually put this
into our collapse toolbar tag.
I've got a very simple
Polymer definition
here to get us started.
And the first thing
we're going to do
is we're going to import that
core media query element.
Then we can drop the
media query element
into the template for
our Polymer element.
And lastly, we're going to
publish that query attribute
to the outside world by adding
it to our attributes list.
And we can bind that value
back to the query property
on the core media query element.
This allows a developer to
actually pass in a breakpoint
and have it reflected
inside of our tag.
So that lets us
know when it's time
to update the appearance
of our element,
but that brings us to the
next point, which is how do we
actually update the
appearance of our element?
Now, to do this we're going to
use one more feature of Polymer
called conditional
template bindings.
As we know, from the top
level of a Polymer element,
there's a template for rendering
content into the shadow dome.
But what's really cool is
that this top level template
can actually contain additional
nested templates which
support data bindings.
So if we use an if
condition inside
of one of our
nested templates, we
can actually bind to the
value of small screen
and only display content
on smaller screen sizes.
As an example, I'm
going to actually try
to grab all of the
links out of my toolbar
using a content element
which I've placed inside
of a menu button, which
is inside of our template
that's only going to render
on smaller screen sizes.
Now from the user's perspective,
the developer who's actually
using our tag, their code is
going to remain the exact same.
They don't need to
change anything.
They just pass in
a few anchor tags.
They set the query attribute
to max width 500 pixels.
And now the toolbar just
does the right thing.
I'll show you an example
of what that looks like.
So over here, as
we start to reach
that 500 pixel
breakpoint, you'll
see that all the
anchor tags are going
to jump out of the toolbar
and into that Menu button.
This is really awesome,
because if the developer using
our element doesn't
have to stress out
about supporting all these
different screen sizes,
it means they can spend more
time doing the things they
enjoy, like adding really
awesome features to their app.
So if you want to grab
the code for this example,
head on over to
GitHub and grab it
at robdodson/collapse-toolbar.
If you want to learn
more about Polymer,
be sure to check out
Addy Osmani's video
on building web components with
Polymer and Eric Bidelman's
video on using Google services
with Polymer elements.
Also be sure to check
out the Polymer website
at polymer/project.org.
And if you haven't done so
yet, make sure to follow us
on Twitter at @polymer and
Google+ at PolymerProject.
Now, I want all of
you get out there
and start
componentizing the web.
It's up to all of us to
build this new ecosystem
of responsive elements.
My name's Rob Dodson, and
thank you so much for watching.